hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called Indiana
Jones and the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull spoilers ahead watch out and stay
safe the movie opens with a US Army
Convoy on its way to a U.S military
installation Hangar 51 when they reach
the gate they are stopped by some
soldiers who are guarding the hangar lo
and behold the U.S army officials in the
Convoy are revealed to be undercover
Russian agents led by Colonel Antonin
defchenko and Dr Arena spalco the
Russians gunned down the U.S soldiers
guarding the gate before making their
way into the warehouse their two
American hostages archeology Professor
Indiana Jones and His companion Mac are
pulled out of a car's trunk it turns out
Jones is supposed to help the Russians
find a crate in the warehouse which
contains a valuable object that
allegedly fell from the sky 10 years ago
Jones was part of the committee formed
by the U.S government to investigate the
object he initially refuses to help but
the Russians threatened to kill his
buddymax so he reluctantly complies
after a while the group and enters the
warehouse and Jones uses gunpowder and
cracked gunshells to locate the crate
because the Box's contents are highly
magnetized it's then revealed that the
crate contains a humanoid form wrapped
in a silver material however as Dr
spalco cuts open the silver Material
Jones grabs hold of a gun passing
another one to his friend Mack Jones
threatens to shoot Dr spalco thinking
she is in complete control of the
situation lo and behold Mack turns the
gun on Jones revealing that he is
actually colluding with the Russians
Jones is taken aback but he manages to
distract the Soviets and get away as the
soldiers chase after Jones spalco
attempts to drive off with the crate
Jones tries to stop her and retrieve the
crate he succeeds but is eventually
forced to abandon the crate and escape
to save his life he walks all night
through the desert until he finds
shelter in a small town however he soon
realizes that there are no inhabitants
other than various mannequins suddenly a
warning siren goes off and it's revealed
that he's in a doom town a town created
for the purpose of an atomic bomb test
realizing that a nuclear bomb is about
to flatten the town Jones scrambles to
find a shelter and ultimately seals
himself in a lead-lined refrigerator
seconds later the bomb detonates and
doom town is totally obliterated the
fridge containing Johns is blasted
across the desert which protects him
from the deadly radiation Jones is
eventually found and he is interrogated
by the FBI about the hangar 51 Heist the
FBI suspects Jones of being a Russian
agent because he helped them break into
Hangar 51 with his associate Mack who
was revealed to be a double agent
however General Robert Ross vouches for
Jones and gets the FBI off his back
General Ross then briefs Jones about
spalco and reveals that she's Stalin's
favorite scientist she specializes in
psychic research science and she is
leading teams from the Kremlin her main
agenda is scooping up artifacts that she
thinks might of paranormal military
applications afterwards Jones returns to
his university in Bedford Connecticut to
teach but he is quickly sent away on a
temporary break with full pay because of
the FBI investigation Jones is dejected
as the past few years have been very
tough because both his dad and Mentor
have passed away to refresh his mind he
decides to go to New York as Jones train
starts to leave he is approached by a
young man named Mutt Williams who
informs him about the danger to his
close archaeologist friend Harold Oxley
this grabs Jones attention and he
cancels his plan to go to New York Jones
and mutt then acquaint themselves with
each other and it's revealed that mutt's
father died in the war and Oxley helped
his mother raise him six months ago
Oxley sent a letter to mutt's mother and
told her that he's in Peru where he has
discovered a crystal skull which looks
similar to The elusive Mitchell Hedges
skull that was stolen from mccader and
mythical lost city made of solid gold in
the Amazon in the 15th century Legend
has it that the ugga tribe of the region
were chosen by the gods seven thousand
years ago to build the giant City out of
solid gold it had aqueducts and paved
roads in technology that wouldn't appear
again for five thousand years
discovering the skull has put oxley's
life life in danger and he is heading to
the arcader with the skull it's believed
that whoever Returns the skull to the
City Temple will be given control over
its power many have lost their lives
looking for the lost city including a
conquistador named Francisco de orelana
who is believed to have been searching
for the skull before Vanishing
mysteriously mutt reveals that his
mother Mary Williams joined Oxley in his
mission but both of them got kidnapped
by goons who were looking for the skull
however Oxley has hidden the skull
somewhere and he refuses to hand it over
to them no matter what so the goons have
ordered Mary to bring the skull to save
oxley's life Matt tells Jones that his
mother knows him and she believes that
only John's can find the skull not then
hands him a letter Mary mailed to him
suddenly 2kgb agents appear and try to
capture them but Jones and munt managed
to escape in the next scene Jones reads
the letter which is a series of Clues
left in a riddle written in a dead
language he decodes the puzzle and
figures out that the skull must be in
Nazca Peru hence the two immediately fly
to Peru there they learned that Oxley
was seen wandering around like like a
madman so he was admitted into a
sanatorium by the locals before he was
kidnapped in Oxley cell at the
sanatorium Jones discovers that he had
drawn a location to oralana's cradle
where he may possibly have hidden the
skull Jones deduces that the Cradle
actually means or Alana's birthplace not
his final resting place that night they
visit orlana's tomb where they are
attacked by two Cemetery Warriors
however Jones effortlessly defeats them
and as they walk through the grave the
two eventually find seven mummified
beings at the bottom of the Grave they
find Francisco to orelana's armor clad
corpse and realize that someone has
already opened them lo and behold Jones
finds the real crystal skull hidden
behind the corpse shocked they prepare
to leave but just then they find
themselves surrounded by Soviets
including Mak devchenko and spalco it
turns out the Russians kidnapped Oxley
and they were the ones who opened
orelina's mummy in search of the skull
Jones and mutter immediately captured
and taken to a Soviet camp in the middle
of the Jungle in Brazil there Jones
reunites with a drunken Mac and chased
him for betraying his trust in his
Defense Max says that he did it for
money and encourages him to join hands
with the Russians then spalco arrives
and reveals that she wants to take the
skull back to a cater and gain the power
of Mind Control she says the Russians
wish to win the war using the greatest
weapon of all the Mind Jones laughs at
the suggestion as he believes that these
are all myths however spellco disagrees
she strongly believes that the skull was
not made by human hands and the proof is
the alien corpse she stole from Hangar
51 and other parts of the world the
alien's bones are also made of crystal
and she hypothesizes that the aliens are
probably distant cousins sent to find a
cater she then brings Jones friend
Professor Oxley who lost control of his
mind due to his overexposure to the
skull apparently the skull stimulates an
underdeveloped part of the human brain
opening a psychic Channel through which
it guides the person to the accader
Jones is relieved to see his friend and
he tries to talk some sense into him but
to no avail spalco reveals that Oxley
can lead them to the accader but she
needs some one to interpret him
therefore she wants Jones to be
hypnotized by the scholars for some
reason the skull doesn't interact with
her Jones is then made to stare into the
eyes of the magical skull and something
transiently takes over him with this
spalco becomes excited and she begins to
imagine Russians placing their thoughts
into the minds of American leaders
meanwhile skull almost takes over Jones
and he starts to violently Shake despite
betraying him Mack worries for Jones and
he asks Falco to stop before the skull's
powers kill Jones however spellco is
unfazed instead she orders Jones to
speak to Oxley by threatening to kill
Mutt and his mother lo and behold mutt's
mother Mary is revealed to be Jon's
ex-girlfriend Marion Ravenwood who had
also been kidnapped Mary is glad to see
Jones but she's also upset with him
because he broke up with her a week
before their wedding as he felt it
wouldn't work out after a brief bicker
fest with his ex Jones deciphers oxley's
riddles and locates the Temple of akater
on their way to the temple Jones learns
that mud is actually his son much to the
astonishment of both of them soon the
family manages to escape after an
intense battle Knack also accompanies
them and it's revealed that he's
actually a CIA agent after surviving
three progressively higher waterfalls
the group enters a cavern shape like a
human head with a waterfall sprouting
from its eyes inside a tunnel they come
across paintings which reveal that the
Extraterrestrial beings taught the ugga
tribes about agriculture suddenly the
group encounters some angry ughha
natives who chase them out of the cave
and into the open on the other side of
the tunnel however Oxley shows the
locals the skull which calms them down
and they Retreat afterwards they climb
up a Mayan pyramid and Jones finds a way
to enter it meanwhile spalco and the
remaining Russians track Jones using a
tracking device Jones and others enter a
temple which contains artifacts from all
over the world next they unlock a huge
Red Door which opens into a chamber with
13 crystal skeletons all of them sitting
in ornate gold Thrones Oxley walks up to
the only skeleton with no head and as he
proceeds to place the skull back Mack
pulls a gun and orders him to stop it
turns out he lied about being a CIA
spalco and the Russian soldiers also
arrive after gunning down the ugka tried
brutally spalco is mesmerized by the
beauty of the skeletons noting that they
are a hive mind of separate bodies but
of a single mentality she then places
the missing skull back where it belongs
the skeleton seemingly comes to life and
Oxley begins to speak in Mayan through
Oxley the crystal skeletons Express
gratitude to spalco for returning the
skull and offer to give her a gift she
asks for knowledge keeping their promise
the skeletons transfer all their
knowledge into spalco's mind in the
process the room begins to rotate and a
portal opens up above threatening to
suck everyone in fortunately Oxley gains
his sanity back and rushes out of the
chamber with others while the Russians
and Mac are sucked in meanwhile espalco
is receiving streams of knowledge the
skeletons begin to converge into one
however the psychic link makes Falco far
too weak to sustain all the knowledge
being sent to her and she pleads for it
to stop sadly the being refuses and it
becomes apparent that it's aware of her
evil intentions which explains why the
skull would not speak to her previously
a raging fire starts in spalco's brain
and rapidly spreads to her whole body
disintegrating her as the rest of the
group escape giant Stone Wheels wrecked
the temple from an elevation the group
watch a giant dark gray alien saucer
emerge from the base of the temple
ground and disappear in the sky the void
is then filled with water from the river
not wonders why a cater was called the
city of gold and Jones answers that the
ugga word for gold is treasure and the
treasure was knowledge the movie that
ends with Jones and Mary marrying With
the blessings of their son mutt thanks
for watching subscribe and hit that like
button to help our Channel grow turn on
the notifications so you won't miss any
of our new videos